the opening scene is set in the year
1879 and we see a small group of
pioneers exploring the unknown
territories amid their Journeys an
immigrant from Ireland named Fergus
coffee falls in love with a resident of
one of these settlements named Maryanne
Stewart one night Marian's family is
attacked by a group of unknown Invaders
sensing the imminent danger the father
instructs his four children to hide in
the basement while he confronts the
attackers alone soon some gunshots the
father's screams can be heard if this
were modern America those sounds would
mean a party but it's not so this
devastates the children but before they
can react they detect movement on the
floorboards above them the children
maintain as much silence as they can but
despite this something breaches their
hiding place and assaults the entire
family the following day Fergus visits
his Lover's house but discovers it empty
he then goes to the neighboring houses
where he notices several dece de ceased
bodies believing that the kidnappers are
hostile Native Americans Fergus decides
to assemble a team of volunteers to
search for the missing people in the
next scene we are introduced to a guy
named William parer who is enjoying a
meal with his wife and their teenage son
Dolby their happy time is soon disrupted
by Fergus who shares the news of the
missing people upon hearing this William
agrees to join the search team Doby's
mother insists that her son also
accompany them as she believes that the
Expedition will help him become a real
man Upon returning to the sight of the
tragedy William notices that the victims
bear peculiar cuts on their necks
leaving him puzzled about the weapon
used by the as salant he also discovers
a mysterious hole in the yard the origin
of which remains uncertain shortly
thereafter the volunteers from various
ranches in the country gather at the
settlement including an administrator
named John clay and a fredman in Pursuit
Of Fortune named Callahan an arrogant
officer Henry Victor along with with a
Cavalry unit takes command of the group
together they bury the deceased in the
yard before embarking on their mission
while on their way Williams horse
unexpectedly gets stuck in freshly dug
ground and topples over however they
don't pay much attention to this and
continue on their Journey unaware of the
fact that there's something covered with
blood in the ground after some time they
spot a young Native American from a
distance Henry Fires at the boy's horse
and rushes to apprehend him William
pulls out a picture of the steuart
family and inquires if he has seen them
but the boy doesn't utter a word seeing
this reluctance Henry binds him to the
cart and orders his men to subject him
to brutal torture forcing him to reveal
the information they need the other
members of the group don't seem to be
happy with this cruelty but they don't
dare to oppose Henry or his men later as
the group gathers around a bonfire
Ferguson Callahan start conversing
sharing stories from their past lives
through their conversation we learn that
Callahan works for Henry as a cook while
Fergus came here from New York because
he couldn't work there Fergus says that
he came here with his sister but she
died on the way from tuberculosis as
night falls Henry instructs three men to
keep guard and shoot if anything seems a
Miss later one of the guards detects
suspicious movement in the field as he
goes to investigate he is suddenly
attacked by an unknown creature
resulting in his death in the morning
Fergus wakes up and sees Henry in Rage
when asked William anded forms him that
four of his men went missing last night
the group then turns to interrogate the
Native American boy who tells them about
a species called the burrowers the boy
claims that the white men have become
the burrowers favorites and they'll be
hunted down one after another Henry and
his men say they're called Tremors and
they've seen that movie so they don't
believe in his claims and proceed to
torture the boy again seeing this the
administrator JN becomes Furious and
kicks one of Henry's men away this leads
to an intense confrontation between
Henry and John but the others managed to
diffuse the tension a few moments later
the group also notices several holes in
the field resembling the one from the
earlier scene afterwards Fergus William
Dolby and John make the decision to
separate from Henry's group and continue
the search mission alone as night falls
the group decides to stop and rest while
gathered around the fire they discuss
their next course of action none of them
have any knowledge of the burrowers
leaving them with no leads to follow a
short while later a sound catches their
attention prompting them to go on high
alert they are nearly ready to open fire
when they discover that the source of
the noise was Callahan who has also
chosen to abandon Henry in the morning
the group resumes their journey in
search of Clues along their path they
encounter numerous holes and soon
stumble upon an abandoned wagon while
taking a break there Doby spots a clump
of blonde hair sticking out from the
ground he curiously proceeds to pull P
it out only to be startled by something
underground the group members gather
around and start digging much to their
astonishment they find the body of a
girl with her eyes open upon hauling her
out they notice a deep cut in her neck
just like the one they saw earlier
suddenly they hear a sound coming from
her shoe on removing it they are shocked
to learn that the girl is still alive as
she is moving her toe the group wonders
why the American Indians are burying the
people alive Fergus is is filled with
worry fearing Maryanne might share a
similar fate the next morning goby is
instructed to take the girl to the
nearest settlement for medical
assistance while the rest of them
continue with their mission as they
Venture into the woods the group senses
someone tailing them soon after a
tribesman lifts up his gun to greet them
but Fergus mistaking it for a threat
opens fire this enrages Jon and he
shoves him off his horse his wrong move
puts the entire group in danger not long
after the tri tribesman open fire and
Jon is the first one to be killed
reacting quickly Fergus William and
Callahan take cover behind a dead horse
before retaliating in the meantime Dobby
and the paralyzed girl stop in the
middle of a field to take a break he
carefully lowers her to the ground and
kisses her on the lips before laying
beside her this is not what your parents
meant by becoming a man Dobby just then
Dobby is attacked by a grayc colored
creature which cuts his neck and spits
liquid paralyzing him just like the girl
the creature then drags him to a
particular area and buries him alive
just like the girl Doby is able to see
and hear but he can do nothing except
for moving his finger back in the woods
the trio stays hidden behind the horse
until the situation cools down during
this William notices some poisonous
plants nearby and tells his friends to
gather them they set it all on fire and
emit a poisonous gas this finally frees
them from the pursuers following this
the three of them Contin continue their
Journey on Horseback despite their
exhaustion as Darkness descends the
group stops by a location and lights a
fire William expresses his sorrow over
the loss of their fallen comrade while
Fergus grapples with concerns about the
brutality of the Native Americans after
a brief conversation William volunteers
to keep watch allowing his two
companions to rest at midnight Fergus is
woken up by an unusual sound and is
startled to discover his comrades
missing in response he quickly grabs his
firearm taking precautionary measures
shortly after Callahan returns to the
campfire and informs Fergus that William
is nowhere to be found suddenly they
hear him screaming so Fergus throws
burning wood towards the same direction
they then spot William desperately
trying to fight some gray creatures with
huge mouths and countless fangs in a
quick response cahan aims at the
creature and shoots scaring them off and
rescuing William however the confront
ation has caused William to suffer from
a cut on his neck just like the other
victims as a consequence he slowly
starts to lose sensation in his limbs
realizing that it's not safe to stop the
group continues their Journey on their
horses even in the darkness while they
ride William asks Fergus to give Do's
mother the cross in case anything
happens to him after riding the whole
day the trio spots a Distant Fire and
moves towards it there they meet a
Native American woman and ask what she's
doing the woman responds in her native
language only understood by William she
promptly recognizes a cut on his neck
and tells him that the burrowers will
come back for him when they ask more
about the species she tells them the
detailed story all about it according to
her the burrowers previously used to
feed on buffalos but when Native
Americans began consuming buffalo meat
the burrowers turned to hunting humans
she explains that the burrowers firstly
poison their prey and bury them to
decompose once the blood thickens and
the organs soften they return to feed
one tribe in particular called the Ute
are experienced in fighting the
burrowers with this information in hand
the group along with the woman head off
in search of the Ute tribe after some
time the woman notices that William's
wound is covered with a rash and says
that it'll now be easier for the
burrowers to find him however Fergus and
Callahan don't understand what she's
saying so they ask William the latter
who fears that his comrades will abandon
him says something else to them after a
long ride William suggests they stop
near a pole and wait for the Ute to find
them the woman insists that it's unsafe
to remain in that spot and urges them to
keep moving nevertheless William
disregards her advice while the rest of
the group members don't understand night
falls and they gather around a bonfire
by this time William's body seems to
have started getting paralyzed and he
can hardly move at midnight the group
hears the sound of the burrowers
prompting them to stay vigilant as soon
as they spot the creatures they start
shooting unfortunately William who is
unable to aim properly ends up shooting
Callahan's leg William is definitely
posting a negative KD for the squad
sensing the imminent danger the woman
resorts to sign language urgently
signaling for them to vacate the area
following this Fergus helps the injured
Callahan and William to get back to
their horses before riding away on the
way they're confronted by two armed men
from the Ute tribe these men noticed
William's injury and decide to take them
with them explaining that they use sick
people as bait the remaining comrades
attempt to resist but the two Ute
tribesmen hold them at gunpoint before
leaving with William in the process one
of the Ute inadvertently drops a belt
containing items belonging to those who
they've used as bait as they depart
Fergus retrieves the belt and discovers
maran's brch within it which leaves him
deeply distraught realizing that their
search is now us useless Callahan
suggests they return home however Fergus
decides to go after William as he must
find a way to destroy the burrowers
before they kill the other families in
the next scene Fergus Ventures through
the woods following the suspicious
sounds and footsteps not long after one
of the Ute tribesmen ambushes him from
behind but Fergus manages to retrieve
his gun and shoot him dead at that
moment he hears Williams anguished cries
prompting him to run in that direction
upon arrival Fergus finds William bound
to a tree paralyzed but before he can
free him the burrowers emerge from the
darkness terrified Fergus tries to run
away but his foot accidentally gets on a
trap causing him to be stuck in the
shackle William tries to fend them off
but he can barely raise his hand to aim
as a result he accidentally shoots a ute
at a distance -2 now following this the
burrowers surround William and begin to
feed on him shortly after one of the
burrowers notices Fergus and slowly
advances toward him Fergus desperately
tries to free his leg but to no avail he
crawls backward nearly triggering
another trap set nearby seeing this he
throws the trap at the creature and
finally frees himself he then notices
the other burrowers lying motionless on
the ground here it's revealed that the
Ute had given certain drugs to William
and feeding on him made the creatures
fall unconscious after this the Ute
points towards a set of Spears which
Fergus uses is to impale all the
creatures despite his efforts the
creatures do not die which makes him
believe that it didn't work out a short
while later the sun rises and its Rays
finally burn the burrowers to death in
the aftermath Fergus brings the wounded
Ute tribesmen to where Callahan and the
women are resting Fergus recounts the
entire incident to Callahan and
emphasizes the importance of keeping the
Ute alive or else the secret ingredient
of the drug will go with him following
this Fergus decides to go to the the
nearest settlement in search of a doctor
leaving the three of them behind in the
next scene Fergus returns to Callahan
and the others with a doctor
surprisingly Henry and his men have
already arrived there before him he also
Witnesses a grim sight Henry has hanged
the Ute tribesmen and the woman to death
without knowing the actual truth Henry
warmly greets his old acquaintance and
boasts his accomplishments when Fergus
inquires about Callahan Henry claims
that he succumbed to his injuries Henry
who still believes that the American
Indians are behind all this vows to
execute all of them faced with this
devastating failure Fergus departs from
the camp without saying a word subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching